well good awesome welcome everybody
thank you for coming to the talk thank
you for choosing me over Detroit hunt
and the C sharp super panel that's also
happening right now I don't think you
will regret it
this talk is billed verses by we're
going to talk about software systems at
Jurassic Park but first my dear friends
let me be the first to say welcome to
Jurassic Park in retrospective we are
going to look very closely uncomfortably
close at Jurassic Park the successes and
failures our organization had during our
first run we put together this
retrospective to share with you the
broader community all the things that we
learned about how to build complex
systems how to choose whether to build
something or whether to buy something so
that we can move into our brave new
future of the next version of Jurassic
Park but more on that later so you may
be familiar with us you may have seen a
documentary made about our work and the
issues that we had it got some notoriety
but it was vastly over dramatized and
negative and it wasn't at all what
really happened our first attempt at
Jurassic Park did have some unfortunate
side effects but only four people died
and I think we learned a lot from the
experience
one of our core problems which we're
going to talk a lot about today was
perfectly perfectly articulated by one
of our consultants dr. Ian Malcolm and
he said we were so preoccupied with
whether we could we didn't stop to think
if we should and I think he was
specifically speaking about our choices
and software and which things we chose
to build and which we chose to buy now
you might be wondering who I am my name
is todd gardner i am the vp of
informatics and automation at a company
called engine engine is the company
behind Jurassic Park a number of
genetics and theme park based companies
here's where I fit into the overall org
structure at the top was our CEO mr.
John Hammond with our general counsel
the top level was robert muldoon the vp
of security and project manager rain
Arnold for operations than me I was in
charge of Informatics Dennis who you
might be familiar with from the from the
documentary reported up through me so
with introductions aside as my good
friend ray Arnold used to say hold on to
your butt's let's get into this so first
we're gonna start with built we've built
a lot of software at Jurassic Park we
made we made a bunch of our own things
and some of it was a good idea and some
of it was a bad idea
but why would we ever choose to build a
piece of software on our own well when
you choose to build something by
definition it is unique it's going to
solve your problem in a way that nobody
else will ever solve it the system we
build for ourselves is unique to our own
problem our own context and our own
tolerance for risk which might have been
slightly lower than then then then your
tolerance for risk no one else no other
piece of software no vendor no
open-source package is gonna solve your
problem quite as perfectly as you're
gonna solve it for yourself
but more importantly build is just fun
especially as developers we don't we
don't want to buy software we don't want
you somebody else's solution we want to
build it ourselves building is fun our
developers want to code we want to solve
new problems and building things taking
on this greenfield side project allows
our developers to to get out of the
tedium of supporting our day-to-day
legacy system and play with new tech new
new ideas new new concepts building
software improves the morale of your
team unless you harness the passion of
the people that you have and some cases
lets you acquire new people at to join
your organization like we did we hired
Dennis to join our team largely by
harnessing his passion for security
systems he really wanted to code his own
door lock videotaping automation system
and by telling him that we would allow
him to build that himself we were able
to bring him into our organization and I
think that was a
benefit for us all as we start digging
in to any given project we realize fast
the devil is in the details you solve a
problem with code if you solve like the
happy path where all of your servers are
online all of your services are fast and
available and the user enters input
exactly as you expect it to that's easy
to get done all the hard parts are what
about the edge cases well if the server
goes offline what if you lose a Ram
module what if the user enters garbage
into the input all these things are
gonna complicate that piece of software
you build and in many cases is going to
be upwards of 80% of the total amount of
work you're gonna do how many of you
have have you know gotten the happy path
done and said oh it's 80% done well the
last 20% takes you know twice or three
times as much time handling all the
weird edge cases those edge cases are
really really important for a piece of
robust software that you're gonna want
to run things when you don't handle the
edge cases you end up in situations like
this here is a situation where we were
suffering a power and systems outage and
we really needed to interact with the
door locks
unfortunately the door locks were
dependent on having on having connection
to power and connection to a network to
lock there was no physical knob to
actually lock the door to keep things we
didn't want in our operation center
totally unrelated to dinosaurs out of
the datacenter
but in a lot of ways we were doing IOT
before IOT was cool this was early IOT
this was a door lock that was powered by
our systems we just didn't handle every
failure case we needed to if you do
choose to build a piece of software
handling your own maintenance time is
gonna add up it's gonna become
incredibly important bugs
patching security integrations debugging
while your headlights are running on the
car batteries thousands little annoying
things that are gonna happen
have to happen to your software months
and months after the original system was
built and this is where the true cost of
successful valuable software lies which
could be as much as 90 percent of the
total cost of a project for example if
you take three months to build a piece
of software and you release it and it's
wildly successful for the company you
might be maintaining it for ten years
well the company's extracting value from
it and that cost really adds up when we
build software and we're going to deploy
it into our own environment
we're responsible for maintaining the
health of that piece of software we're
gonna have to spend time not only
building it initially but building in
all of the observability and monitoring
and metrics gathering that we'll need to
know to see does this piece of software
work effectively make sure that we know
when it isn't make sure that we know if
the fences are no longer being
electrified we should know about that
right away and this is gonna take a lot
longer than you think
to get it right because you're gonna
have a lot of cycles of failure where
your systems are going to go offline
you'll realize oh we didn't have that
kind of metric we weren't monitoring for
that kind of failure case and then for
on your alerting side you're gonna have
to find the right balance of being woken
up at 2:00 a.m. when you want to be
woken up at 2:00 a.m. but not being
woken up at 2:00 a.m. every day finding
that right balance is really important
and really hard when you're building
large complex systems of course
maintenance time is going to come due
when you've forgotten how the whole
thing works it's not gonna come after
you've just built a piece of software
and shipped it it's gonna come years
later when you've moved on to bigger and
better things or maybe it's the next
developer who's coming to your company
and taking over it you'll have moved on
to other things but you'll have to
remember how to clear the caches in your
system or recycle underlying services or
upgrade the infrastructure or check the
internal logs all kinds of things that
are gonna crop up when you don't
remember how to do it anymore and you'll
have to depend on documentation that you
might leave for yourself or your team
left for you but honestly that doctor
it probably sucks it's probably
incomplete incomplete
and often it's just wrong and you're
gonna have to spend time understanding
which one of those things is it triaging
the system yourself to figure out what
is true what is not true so that you can
do the maintenance work you need to do
that's all time-consuming and expensive
of course an outage with the system
actually goes down is gonna compile all
of those other stressors of maintaining
your software with the added stress of
your VP shoulder surfing over you asking
is it fixed yet is it fixed yet it's the
service online customers are waiting for
you
outages are part of this maintenance
time as we all know things don't always
go as planned
sometimes systems go down sometimes
electrified fences go offline do you
know how to restart it can we get across
the compound to flip the breaker without
dying these are important things to
consider when thinking about how's your
system going to break if your system
does go offline are your backups good
and current how do you know when's the
last time you actually restored from
your backups all these things you don't
necessarily think about them until the
outage happens now a common concept that
goes along with maintaining software is
a concept called the bus factor which
some of you might be aware of the bus
factor is how many people in your
organization would need to be hit by a
bus for you to be in trouble so much of
our knowledge about how our systems work
how they function is locked up in our
heads and we can't get them down in
documentation or it's just not
cost-effective to get it down in
documentation our engineers our support
staff our operations people know how the
company works and how much that
information is stretched around is going
to drive what your bus factor is of
course we didn't really have buses in
Jurassic Park
we did have Dilophosaurus and so we had
a Dilophosaurus factor how many of our
engineers would have to be eaten by a
Dilophosaurus for us to be in trouble
and unfortunately for us that number was
one
one engineer had to be in by
Dilophosaurus and we were in trouble
having that load Dilophosaurus factor
creates all kinds of sustainability
issues in your organization how are your
teammates gonna come up and and help you
out when you become unavailable this
could happen for lots of reasons outside
of Dilophosaurus --is large
organizations especially tend towards
creating fiefdom zuv knowledge as they
specialize their teams and are not
really good at sharing that knowledge
between teams which although it might
make you more efficient it dramatically
lowers your Dilophosaurus factor
standards documentation and transparency
can help but you can never be truly
redundant one particular time that
you're asked parked we were building
this large piece of software and we
needed some outside help and so we'd
hire three different consulting teams to
help us build different parts of the
software unfortunately our management
you know jon hamm and he didn't really
understand how software works all the
time and so he he didn't scented each of
these teams on their own you know how
many features they had shipped and
nobody was really incentivized on the
success of the project and so they were
actually incentivized to hurt each other
by not taking the load off of somebody
else or not making the documentation
completely correct for how some of it
for how one of the other teams might
want to integrate it which led to all
kinds of infighting where the team from
this consultancy would be sabotaging the
team from the other one in order to make
themselves look good but the product
just burned so all these things come
together and we have to figure out some
actual numbers on how much it's going to
cost us to build a piece of software
engineers are expensive it's gonna take
time and money for them to build
something and then as we've already
talked about that maintenance time is
going to be upwards of ten times the
total cost of building it and so we
found this calculator online that lets
us can't quantify some of this where we
can put in things like the number of
employees required to build a piece of
software and what we what the average
employee salary is so at the time
Denis we were trying to justify Denis
building a piece of security software
and we thought it would require two
employees and at the time we were paying
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars in
average salary they thought we would be
able to build this thing in two weeks
and need one day a month going forward
to maintain it do patches that sort of
thing in comparison we looked at well
what if we just buy it
we found a comparable piece of security
software that we could get a license to
for about three thousand dollars a year
and so if we compare these things we can
figure out well what does it actually
cost us to build if we just multiply the
salary out over the number of days and
see it cost us nine thousand dollars to
build it which isn't so bad I mean
that's fine but the thing that really
kills us is that that one day a month
adds up that one day a month turns out
to be 78 hundred dollars a year every
year that we are holding on to this
software which totally kills any any
benefit of strict financially building
it versus if we could have acquired the
piece of software for $3,000 so we ran
the numbers and that that didn't
actually seem to seem to pay off but you
know there's other benefits to running
your own software right it's fun to
build it you get it all do all kinds of
things so maybe maybe four thousand
dollars is worth is worth it that that
loss but the strict costs are not the
only one we need to consider each of our
companies is doing something amazing at
the heart at Jurassic Park we were
building dinosaurs why would we build
security software when we could be
building dinosaurs that's opportunity
cost is what could you be doing with
your time that serves the core of your
business the core of your organization
or of your team what could you be doing
to further that goal opposed to building
a given piece of software and that is
where so much opportunity is missed
where we waste time building some little
print to PDF thing instead of buying a
piece of software or we build our own
CRM instead of buying one we do all
these other things that aren't part of
our core business we did this all the
time at Jurassic Park we weren't really
focused on building a bigger badder
meaner dinosaurs which is what would
have made us successful so we look all
that together think about the costs
required to build theirs first the
creation time how much time are we are
we going to invest our developers our
operations our testing our designers to
build out the software initially and
then thinking in terms that it might be
as much as 10 fold if it's successful
what is the time it's going to require
to maintain this software over time
we're going to throw it into our
environment we're gonna really do some
stuff with it and what is the
opportunity cost what could what else
could we have done what other dinosaurs
could we have created as you make
decisions and you make more decisions to
build software your your portfolio
software that you're gonna maintain is
gonna become larger and larger and more
complex at Jurassic Park we had all of
the major project with all of the
problems of a major theme park and a
major zoo and a major software provider
and our computers weren't even up on
their feet yet we didn't have a whole
lot of what I call organizational
maturity we weren't able to really like
understand how to be a high-performing
software team if you have lots and lots
of custom software you're gonna need
boring things like software ownership
policies who's going to own when changes
are going to go into this software who
makes the decisions on change management
when you need to change an API and
inform all the downstream downstream
consumers planning horizons of when a
system is going to be retired when new
ones gonna go out online when things are
gonna change when things are gonna get
patched all of these you know
organizational maturity things that
you'll have to do in order to be
effective and your systems not to go
offline but as an engineer that doesn't
seem very fun Engineers don't want to
sit and change control meetings they
want to sling code and so as you think
about building more and more pieces of
software to be successful at building
everything you need is going to demand a
very high level of
organizational maturity of you and so
the question to ask yourself is do you
have it is your organization capable of
building all of the software themself
and even if you are
do you want it because frankly maturity
is overrated and those kind of things
are really boring and they're required
lots and lots of layers of middle
management that are gonna get in the way
of your true organizational mission if
you buy pieces of software or buy
services to provide them those change
control things are already baked into
those packages and you can get away with
being a very immature organization that
delivers the core piece of software that
is really unique for your business and
get to just play around and have a good
time focusing on the one thing that
really matters so those are some stories
about building we built a lot of
software Jurassic Park probably too much
but we did buy a lot too and so in the
context of this what do I mean by buying
software because there is software we
still buy but a lot of people you know
just download software off of github
they pull up a open-source package and
they weave it into something else
they're doing I think there's a lot of
parallels in what to consider between
using somebody else's software whether
you exchange money for it or not versus
whether you build it yourself and so for
the purposes of this talk I want to
think of it as build versus use the same
challenges are going to apply if you
pull somebody else's package versus you
are buying a service or a box software
or whatever so probably the most
important benefit to using somebody
else's software to buying software from
a vendor is that it's fast I have
problem x vendor has a solution to
problem X I give them money I have now
solved problem X done no developers no
project plan we're just done it's great
we bought a lot of things at Jurassic
Park we needed a smart piece of touring
equipment to take our visitors around we
could have designed it ourselves we
could have built our own vehicles that
did you know everything we needed but we
could buy it from
bored and just like clamp it to a track
and get like 90% of what we needed right
there and did it so much faster without
having to invent our own vehicle
manufacturing process and that enabled
us to focus on the few things that were
truly unique about our problem
things like night vision poison
resistant windows and a t-rex strength
roll cage which didn't come as
pre-defined packages from Ford
unfortunately but as I think we all know
even though buying is fast buying sucks
as developers we do not want to buy
somebody else's software and implement
it if you walk into your job on Monday
and you said hey we just signed a big
contract with sa P and you're on the
implementation team that would not be a
great time for everybody I am sure that
is probably not what developers want to
spend their time doing the software we
buy never works quite the way you need
it to it never behaves quite the way
you'd want it to and when something goes
wrong there's often little to do when
the t-rex proofs Sun roof breaks except
you know find the phone number and call
Tier one support and try and figure out
their way through it we bought a lot of
big pieces of software at Jurassic Park
here's a here's an image of one of our
implementation phone calls taking place
when we were installing it we have this
big project that had been going on for
three years it's a three year project we
had two dozen outside consultants to
help us manage this we had buy-in from
the top of our organization John Hammond
himself had approved that we were going
to implement this piece of software we
had hundreds of planning design
coordination implementation meetings the
kind of meetings that just pack your
whole day your schedule is bricked from
8 a.m. to 5 p.m. every day
we even had a project manager with a
shotgun ready to step in in case
something went wrong
despite that the project failed
over half of software implementation
projects fail according to this survey
from CIO magazine in in 2016
over half over half of software
implementation projects fail and we
still just keep doing it we still think
it's a great idea buying isn't the
surefire plan for success it's not
always going to work out and there's a
lot of reasons behind that as you start
going down the process of buying a piece
of software the first thing you're
probably going to run into our vendors
vendors ready to tell you about the
solution that they have sales
presentations box lunches they trying to
convince you that they have the solution
to all of your problems but of course
they don't they'll probably try and sell
you on one of two options on how their
software works but most vendors tend to
fall into one of these two kind of silos
the first is that there are industry
standard is that if you have this kind
of problem we have the solution to this
kind of problem we sell it in this box
you just have to install it and the
problem will be solved we had some
problems like this at Jurassic Park we
had a complex engineering effort that we
call design to hatch and it was part of
our genetics program we would design the
genome go through a number of testing
series synthesis synthesize an egg
manage the egg until it hatches that was
our design to hatch face and there's all
kinds of complex things that went into
that in some cases different steps in
that were truly unique things that we
needed to do but in others we have the
same problems that everybody does we
needed to manage eggs keep them at a
certain temperature until they hatched
well they have to do that with chickens
too they have to do that with all kinds
of eggs and we were able to purchase a
piece of robotic egg management software
that just plugged right into our process
and we had to do nothing at all in fact
adopting the process that came out of
this piece of software improved our
efficiency because we weren't as good at
it as as this piece of software that was
we used worldwide most software assumes
a given flow of work inside of it a
given process that your users or your
systems are going to follow and in some
cases the flow of work that they expect
is what you're ultimately buying you're
buying somebody to tell you what
process is for this so that you don't
have to figure it out for yourself we
saved a lot of headache by just taking
their process and moving forward with it
another great example of industry
standard is when you're buying operating
systems very few of us need to code our
own operating system and although we
considered it a Jurassic Park we ended
up using a standard UNIX variant which
allowed us to onboard interns very very
quickly when they came into our into our
system immediately recognizing the
underlying code the underlying system
that was operating the other option that
vendors will try and sell you down is
that it's highly configurable you can
take our software and you can tailor it
to the specific needs of your business
so in other cases in our design to hatch
system we needed something that was
really configurable there were some
genetic things that we were doing in
Jurassic Park that were truly unique and
nobody in the world had ever conceived
of it we needed software that could
adapt and change and be exactly what we
wanted it to be a very common use case
that might be relevant to all the
software people in the room would be
Atlassian's JIRA product which is highly
configurable - project management and
issue tracking in software spaces it
allows you to change all kinds of things
about what fields you're gonna track
what workflow you're gonna go through
what alerts get sent out and what stages
things can go through unfortunately you
have to assume that your process is
superior to theirs as you're saying that
our process and building software in the
case of JIRA is so much better than what
anybody else is doing that we need to
configure a tool to codify our process
because it's just so much better
unfortunately if your process isn't that
good you've just made changing it all
the harder by coding it into another
piece of software to make it go wrong
faster something that all vendors that
you'll have a problem with all vendors
of buying a piece of software is this
concept called vendor lock-in so if you
go down that path of buying a piece of
software you need to think about this
the more you customize a piece of
software the more you tailor it to your
needs
the more you're locking yourself in to
continue using that piece of software
the more expensive it's going to be for
you to ever leave that piece of software
you're making that cost to switch away
from it more and more for every time you
configure it add your own custom code to
it or further complicated recreating all
of that configuration is expensive and
the vendors are aware of this in fact
they're optimizing their product for it
it's a term that they call being sticky
vendors do everything they can to make
their products sticky and you need to be
aware of it as consumers as you choose
to use a product and you continue to
adapt it if you're using a piece of code
that requires you to write in their own
custom language or use their own custom
way of defining properties you're making
it harder for you to leave a really
common company or a company that is
really good at being sticky is
salesforce comm same buddy work for
salesforce com
no that's fine this isn't bad about them
this is a great product for them but the
product that they launched allowed you
as a developer to acquire a license to
salesforce.com
you would code your own custom things in
there but you wouldn't use this an
industry standard language you had to
use their language which was called apex
which didn't work like any other
language was theirs so every line of
code you'd write in apex was bound to
salesforce you couldn't ever copy it out
and put it into your own system the
database design and how you'd go about
querying it was also custom it was not
quite tables and you would query it
using a language called
schakal which it wasn't quite sequel it
was just hard enough that you couldn't
copy it out and use it anywhere else
they made their product very very sticky
and they are one of the largest cloud
companies in the world together all of
these problems with dealing with vendors
buying software and the complex
implementations of them lead to this
effect called the not invented here
syndrome that a lot of company
tend to have buying installing an
integrating software often sucks and so
we have a tendency as engineers to over
build to avoid that pain we build our
own monitoring systems our own tour
operations our own telephone systems our
own video surveillance and door locks we
had not invented here syndrome bad at
Jurassic Park here's an example of a
case where we chose to buy a piece of
software because we we thought that
somebody else could solve this problem
better than us so at Jurassic Park we
had some volatile assets that we needed
to manage and there was a hot startup
coming out at the time there was a hot
startup coming at the time called raptor
and they were supposed to specialize in
securing the most unsecure ball volatile
assets around they were featured in all
kinds of like financial technology and
cryptocurrency and some physical assets
and we thought that this is the company
that we want to work with for helping us
with our volatile assets they were
featured in a bunch of tech press the
community buzzed about them and so we we
implemented them and it looked good
everything looked favorable at the
beginning but a lot of the capabilities
that they claim to have didn't quite
manifest when we started putting it
together a lot of the things that they
said they could do were kind of pumped
up by the venture capitalists to back
them and not really in the core product
itself and like many other software
startups as core it wasn't a profitable
company it had taken lots and lots of
outside money and didn't make any of its
own didn't make enough to continue its
operation now there's lots and lots of
great software vendors they're
unsustainable early on but the trouble
happens that if something goes wrong
they might not have the foundation to
survive it and in the case of Raptor
Raptor had a lot of customers in the
cryptocurrency space and buried
somewhere deep in there in their
software product they had dependency on
this package called a vent stream
now some of you might have heard of the
event stream situation that happened
event stream is an open-source package
that was maintained by by a very nice
gentleman and it it was just a small
library at the core of many pieces of
software but the person supporting it
was overworked wasn't getting paid had a
lot of other things on his plate and
when a kind person said hey I want to
take this over here I have a reputation
I'm good
they handed over the project seemed good
except the person who took over the
project injected a cryptocurrency theft
mechanism into it and deployed it out
out via the NPM package management
system which was then picked up by all
of these other pieces of software
including some core pieces that were
used by raptor all of a sudden raptor
had this tremendous liability all of its
cryptocurrency customers were seeing
money taken out of their accounts and
they couldn't cover it so i'm late one
Thursday night Raptor just disappeared
Oracle acquired the assets shut down the
company and Raptor was gone which is the
unfortunate side effect of companies
that aren't underlying sustainable is
when something goes wrong they can just
disappear on Monday they can be we're
crushing it and everything's great and
on Tuesday they're filing for bankruptcy
so it comes down to sustainability both
sustainability in a vendor that you're
looking at or sustainability in that
open-source package is how are they
going to continue how are they going to
still be there for you when you need
them if you're depending if your
business is depending on an open-source
package that's entirely maintained by
one developer in his off hours and in
the basement that might not be the core
business that you want to build on maybe
you want to contribute to them maybe you
want to donate to that open source
developer maybe you want to give some
time or energy back to them or maybe
that's a case where you want to build
your own if you think that something
truly unique to what you're doing
so we talked a bit about build and we
talked a bit about Buy
but how do we how do we decide so far
those are just been anecdotes about how
things have failed for us in the past
and we need to look forward to the
future and how are we going to make
these decisions about the new things
that we're gonna build for the last one
we we definitely had some some
well-deserved mud on our face we failed
as an organization I failed I probably
got too far away from the software in my
VP role but only four people died
our lawyers dead our project managers
dead
mr. Arnold is dead and Dennis is dead
but that's it that was all it was we can
do better how can we do better for the
next time and so I thought of five
questions that I need to ask myself and
asked of my team as we're moving forward
into the next Jurassic Park questions
like what is the impact of failure when
we're making a decision how wrong can it
go let's say let's say hypothetically
everything goes wrong I know it's not
likely but let's just humor me and say
everything goes wrong the power goes out
the fences go down all at the same time
what's gonna happen for this decision
that we're looking at right now what is
the impact of failure do people die does
the business lose a bunch of money is
the engineering team inconvenienced to
something just show up in the logs what
are we talking about here because we
should focus on when people die and when
the business loses a whole lot of money
those are the important decisions that
we need to get right and alert getting
sent at the wrong time maybe we don't
need to spend a week and analyzing what
the right decision is here so don't get
sucked into analysis paralysis focus on
the big decisions that are really going
to matter
second when we're deciding on something
do we need competitive advantage or
competitive parity and these are the
words that like a bunch of our MBA
consultants like to use and I don't know
they're big nasty words so one of our
other architects that we're working with
right now
Dillon Beatty phrased it this way that
if you couldn't sell it buy it
this is a much more eloquent way of
putting it but we need we need clarify
because in this open-source world we're
going to depend on a bunch of new
open-source package packages we should
think about if we couldn't contribute it
we should buy it if we're making a
decision about a piece of software and
we don't think that software is novel or
interesting enough that we could wrap it
up and put it out as an open-source
package that other people could use then
is it really novel and interesting and
valuable enough for us to spend our time
on should we just go use it from
somebody else
if we're thinking about building our own
web framework but we don't think this is
good but this is interesting you're
unique enough that we could go out and
put it up next to react and view an
ember and angular and the rest well do
you really need to build it then or
could you just use something from
somebody else question three what is our
bias all organizations all teams have
bias here's a picture of us doing some
mob programming we're reviewing a bunch
of Dennis's systems after he left while
we reviewed it we noticed a bunch of
bias in his choices there was over three
million lines of C code in there and
there was a tremendous bias for building
every little subsystem he built himself
every single thing that we needed to
call out to if we needed to get water
pressure for our sprinkler system he
would call out and build that himself he
built every subsystem without himself
without ever reaching out to third
parties which seemed wasteful it seemed
like we didn't really need to do that
game the system a lot of control to
short-circuit the system should he ever
need it which I'm kidding I'm not sure
why you would ever want to be able to do
that question four what can we do with
our time instead so should we build our
own security system or should we build a
bigger scarier dinosaur and I think when
we weigh those together I think the
answer is clear we got to build a bigger
scarier dinosaur that's what we're good
at that's what our organization excels
at doing and we need to put all of our
attention there
and the fifth question and probably the
most important of them is is it
sustainable this question applies
whether you're building it buying it or
using it from an open source provider if
you're building something yourself are
you mature enough of an organization do
you have the time and resources to
commit to not only solving the core
problem but solving all the edge cases
getting it all the way to production
managing it once there making sure it's
available are you are you capable of
doing that with this new venture or if
you're gonna buy it is the company
you're going to buy it from are they
still going to be around in two years
when you need them are they the an
organization that's going to be there to
support you when you need it or if
you're going to pull it from an open
source provider are they built in such a
way that there is a corporate sponsor
behind that package or there is a fee
that is being paid to them to the
contributor to make up for their time
making sure that you're not depending on
something that is just going to
disappear when somebody burns out and
walks away so these are important
questions that I think we need to ask
for the next time next time we're gonna
do this right one of the problems that
we had with the last park was that it
was just it was just too remote it was
too far away it was too isolated we
couldn't respond to the needs on the
ground fast enough when we had an issue
and so I'm super excited to announce our
next park right here we're finalizing
plans to build the next part right near
by is part of Hyde Park in London
further amplifying the cultural center
that is this great city we're actively
hiring especially in Raptor operations
so if you're looking please come by for
an application afterwards the last time
when we were building up our systems it
was it was not very flexible it was it
was too concrete and so this next time
we're gonna write it in modular
JavaScript all of our systems for the
new Jurassic Park are going to be Java
Script and we're hired we've hired a new
chief developer
named Newman who's fresh out of a code
school after leaving the US Postal
Service and he's got some great ideas
about complex distributed event systems
that we want to try but we're already
coming up these up against these
questions about what parts of this do we
build and what parts of it do we buy and
so to kind of amplify my points here I
want to walk you through one of the
decisions that we've just gone through
recently which is how are we going to
monitor our system for when it's going
to go down so because the new Jurassic
Park is built on JavaScript and like a
lot of JavaScript apps they break and
sometimes unpredictable ways we need to
understand when it breaks and alert the
proper people so that we can respond to
issues so for the next park we're
already we've already been looking into
this and we've been weighing a couple of
different options so first we looked at
building it and what would be required
if we were to build our own monitoring
system and so first we would need to
write some JavaScript as like an agent
something that we could collect data
from all of our other systems with and
we we know how to write JavaScript we
doing all of our systems in JavaScript
we could probably do that but then we
need somewhere to put all of our
monitoring data so we could look at open
source packages like elastic and and
show some of it in there and that kind
of solves part of the problem now we're
collecting data and storing data but I
also want a report on it and see
well what happened yesterday what's
going wrong and so we'll need some
visualization tools so we could use
Cabana or a number of graph ahna or a
number of different tools to look at
that but that's kind of a happy path
that's that's the core things you need
for this system to come online well
you're also gonna want alerting built
into that right you're gonna want to
know when something interesting happens
and you're going to look into the data
and see about anomalies of when
something is increasing importance and
then you're gonna figure out well what
happens if the system goes down we need
to back it up what infrastructure we're
gonna run on how many servers do we need
what's the security do we need to lock
down our sir are we putting sensitive
data in our logs do we need to like keep
this secure what happens if the
monitoring goes down who monitors the
monitors and if so who monitors the
monitors
our monitors how do you solve these
problems so here's where we get into all
those neatly little details they're
gonna eat up so much of our time trying
to solve this core problem so we were
handed through that calculator and we
put together a project plan of well what
do we think it would take so we thought
we thought Newman could probably put it
together himself and we're paying Newman
a little bit less because he's he's a
newer developer we're paying him
$100,000 he thinks he can build this in
four weeks and we think we need about
one day a month of maintenance just to
make sure that all the apps are running
smoothly all the agents are deployed
we're gathering the right data but as
part of gathering this we looked out on
the marketplace for what else could we
buy and so we found a comparable tool
for about $2,700 a year and so like all
right well does this does this ever pan
out so just using those numbers we see
it cost of 76 hundred dollars to build
the system originally but another thirty
two hundred dollars every year to
maintain it that one day a month adds up
and so if you compare that to other
systems this never actually is a pure
good idea like you're losing money every
year well that's one facet of this but
what if we go down the path of buying it
and is that sustainable is that a good
idea so we looked at one vendor and we
looked at sustainability specifically
with if we were to go to them are we
going to are they still going to be
there when we need them one of the
biggest factors in sustainability and
software companies is outside money if a
company takes a bunch of outside
investment that outside investment puts
a tremendous amount of pressure on that
company to grow and in fact numbers show
that 99% of the time a company takes
outside investment will fail so if you
look at that that's a strong signal that
that company might not be around later
and speaking with the leadership of the
track team they've said they've never
taken any they don't intend to and that
they are already internally profitable
but most importantly we have to consider
our opportunity cost here so we could
spend this I mean it's not that much
money we could go out and build our own
monitoring tool I'd be fine or we could
take those two weeks
for weeks and one day a month and build
a bigger scarier dinosaur for our London
Park and I think that's what we all want
right we want a bigger scare your
dinosaur here in London should we build
monitoring software or should we buy
monitoring software and have more time
for dinosaurs I think that's clear I
think Newman's going to agree so that
was build versus buy to kind of wrap up
some questions that you should ask in
your teams when you're trying to make
this decision one what is the impact of
failure figure out should you even spend
time thinking about this or should just
go with your gut and move on because
it's unimportant second could you sell
it if you're thinking about building
something but you don't think it's
interesting and valuable and unique
enough that you could sell it then it
might be not as novel as you think it is
and you should just buy something
understanding what your bias is simply
so that you can recognize it and make a
conscious decision about whether or not
you're doing something just because you
tend to always build or you tend it to
always buy and think about it what could
you do instead if you were instead of
buying something or instead of building
something what if you took those two
weeks four weeks six weeks whatever it
would take and you invested it somewhere
else in a core product extension
whatever in building a scarier dinosaur
and regardless of which path you go down
understand whether or not it's
sustainable is the the path that you've
chosen sustainable by your company or
the vendor or the provider that you've
chosen and with that those are the five
questions I think are important for us
to ask ourselves we were choosing
whether to build buy or use software and
the words of our consultant dr. Ian
Malcolm well there it is thank you
and with that aside if there's any
questions I'd be happy to check there's
a bunch of stickers up here if you'd
like any no I mean if you if you
recognize that your organization has a
bias to build which a lot of engineering
organizations do have that bias try not
look at where did that come from so are
you building because you're really good
at it and it's been successful for you
historically in which case yes continue
if your past decisions on building
things yourself has left your
organization and in a healthy
sustainable state keep doing it but if
the last couple times you've chosen to
build something it ended up a hot mess
and you didn't really want to run it
anymore and the developer who is running
it ended up quitting maybe that's not
such a good decision anymore and you
should recognize that you're making that
decision implicitly there was one
organization that was in Jurassic Park
that had it's a it's a large company
where I live they have a tremendous bias
for building the not invented here
syndrome is strong with them they have
invented their own cloud layer that
looks a lot like digitalocean
does the same thing as digitalocean but
is their own thing they built their own
Dropbox and their own Twitter to solve
basically the same problems but only in
their company like it's just theirs and
those don't really make sense like none
of those systems work well nobody who's
ever been at this company has enjoyed
using them but they just like owning
their own software they don't trust
external vendors regardless of who they
are
all right thank you very much
enjoy your evening if you have any other
questions you want chat with me up here
feel free thank you
[Applause]